we scared we don't trust the police why
do we live in the most free country in
the world and got to walk around here in
fear this morning there was some
security footage released by the police
department showing potentially a robbery
happened before this incident occurred
does that affect any of this in your
mind it does not the fact that there has
been a the the prosecutor who would have
to by the way prosecute the police
officer has been completely non
transparent with video technology today
I don't I think all of these again are
meant to distract from the basic fact
that an 18 year old was walking down the
street and that officer decided to be
judged jury and executioner it doesn't
matter if it's Michael if that was
Michael not because if it is my don't
mean that he still deserved to die over
a pack of cigarettes or whatever it is
that they're saying that he took do you
see a problem with the destruction of
private property and how this is all
played out you wish it played out
differently no I believe that the only
reason we have this attention is because
of the looting you're writing I'm a
business owner so I understand both
sides of course I wouldn't want my any
of my businesses burned down broken into
but without these business broken into
none of y'all will be out here because
that's the only reason people tweeted
people got on Facebook people Instagram
it was just a peaceful everybody get
together you know justice for Mike Brown
and everybody leave we wouldn't have the
national attention we have now and it'll
be swept under the rug hey we are we're
free
look at this is not a black or white
thing a woman come over here is not a
lady or man T it's a real thing we
should bury we let our keys go outside
the place
our fear the police not murdering our
teeth that was pretty execution of my
crown and then we wanted answers today
and it's nothing but long lifted what
would justice look like in this case how
do you think things need to play out for
peace to be restored here well yeah I
guess the most important thing is true
to come to light there has been no
transparency the release of the number
of shots that he sustained that's basic
information that should have been known
within days so this entire investigation
has been botched from the beginning the
non-disclosure lack of transparency
again this is not the way it should be
done and I'm very concerned and alarmed
by it